what is this like the 47th movie with
the title fear I feel like they come out
with a fear every couple years I feel
like I should have 2023 fear 2023 movie
review in the title of this I don't know
if I will we'll see
[Music]
so fear is what happens when January has
actually been really enjoyable in terms
of entertainment you have that walking
on eggshells feeling you're like we're
gonna have to pay the pipe or hard for
this [__] eventually that is this week a
week that looked pretty bone dry I was
like what do I watch any meaning yeah
sure that one the January horror film
that had no press screening where I live
me embargo lifted today none of this
looks good so this is a low budget
horror psychological Thriller film about
a group of friends they come to this
crickety-ass old hotel and this place is
making them visualize the fear they're
coming increasingly paranoid and then
you see the concepts which could have
been interesting before the end game bad
CGI starts up now out the gate I will
say this movie does feel like straight
to DVD I say straight to DVD because
this feels like a straight to DVD movie
before Blu-rays were a thing you know
2003 2004. the thing about this movie is
the script it's the screenwriting it's
the classic case of it feels like
friends who are just sitting around they
thought of really interesting or cool
things that could be in a horror movie
we've all done that with our friends
because that's a really fun thing to do
with your friends but if you're gonna
execute it if you're gonna actually do
it you have to take these Concepts and
put them in a movie that works or you
end up having what this movie is which
the horror movie things that are going
down are actually cool in concept but
we're not looking at concept we're
looking at execution the execution
right down to how the characters are
acting with each other alone which is
this dude because a drop of water on his
head when he's sleeping he was like I'm
gonna go into the attic and figure this
[__] out or you can call the front desk
I mean granted probably wouldn't do you
much good in this hotel but at least
show the audience you're trying a film's
job is to be a tour guide to guide the
audience with the characters of the
audience can actually buy or believe
that the characters are acting and
reacting in the way they are in the film
now this dude's just kicking open doors
in the Attic like hey I'm gonna figure
this out I'm probably gonna run across
some really sketchy rating material and
some pictures to show the audience
what's happening almost like I'm in a
movie right it just comes across that
way there's this weird coveted side plot
in the movie tube which to be fair to
the film it's never called covid it's
just a variance which again on paper
makes sense your film is about fear
paranoia
what can the audience relate to and yeah
you're right the audience will be able
to watch this and be like what the [__]
do you think I want to be taken there
for my escapism horror film the audience
knows about isolating social distancing
and everything the characters in this
movie were not doing in this movie TI's
character might have the not coveted
variant he's in his hotel room his own
hotel room alone in bed doors closed we
know that is isolating but all the
characters in this movie were like all
right he's isolated
let's say we go get him and throw him
into the basement so he can be isolated
again I know scared group of people the
theme of the entire film is fear and
fear makes people act irrationally but I
feel like in this case to be like yeah
that scares the [__] out of me but he's
in his room for the time being so let's
just leave him there let's I'm so afraid
I'm not going to go near him the whole
virus for the sake of fear and paranoia
thing just it just felt awkward and out
of place movie was much more interesting
when it left that and then went on to
focusing on other people's demons like
that's where the movie thrived I'm using
thrived very Loosely when the movie was
at its best
I'm using best Loosely it's when I saw
the potential and then yeah at the end
there's this weird swirly bad CGI
monster thing it just doesn't look good
look in the end there were a couple of
ways people got dispatched when you
actually see the fear going down what
they see versus what's actually
happening that was actually pretty cool
giving credit for credits do if you
could have those moments in a script and
in a film that worked that complemented
it could have had ourselves a pretty
badass time here this is a film actually
I haven't said this too often I'm gonna
go ahead and say it now this is a movie
I hope gets remade there is something
here in the concept the horror element
in here it fell flat for me the
psychological Thriller elements I
actually did like again in concept I
walked out of this movie knowing one
thing that I'm not gonna remember in T
minus one day yep already forgot all
right so fear you know what any of them
any of the movies titled fear doesn't
have to be this 2023 one what do you
think of fear whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]